Ladies and gentlemen,
today we are uncovering quite possibly the largest giveaway scam in history.
And the crazy thing is that it's still going on right now.
As we speak guys, I am talking of course,
about Instagrammer, Jay magaziney.
Now I'll introduce you to this guy. I'll give you everything to first.
Let me say he's, uh, he's very requested. And, uh,
I actually put together something for you guys. Let's watch.
Just
to give you this food. Everybody that got
[inaudible].
This is the side that Jay magaziney wants you to see.
He has a bunch of posts on his Instagram, everywhere,
where he's giving away money and he wants to be seen like that.
He wants to be seen like, sort of like a Mr. B's 2.0, Mr. Altruism.
He's constantly giving away money.
But the question is where did he get this money to be giving away to everyone?
Well, he'll tell you,
he owns an Academy where he teaches trading and he also owns a clothing
company called Masini Italy.
I got a clothing line. I got an Academy.
We felt we keep stocks.
Now, according to him,
the clothing company alone is worth $8 million.
Pretty impressive for an influencer who has 1 million followers.
Most people on Instagram who have 1 million followers are making a decent
living, but they're not making anywhere near $8 million.
$8 Million net worth. This is what the company's estimated up.
When you start digging deeper,
we find out why Jay Masini is getting so many orders on it.
This is going to be a mystery box,
minimum order of three MSI products in order to win in order to win
maybe $10,000, maybe 20,000, maybe 30,000.
See, this is how Jamie Zeni really makes his money.
He does giveaways where he will say for the next X number of orders,
I'll be giving you back money. And it's not like an insignificant amount.
This is often life-changing amounts of money,
but the requirement is you have to buy products from his site.
Magaziney italy.com in order to enter to win. Now on the FTCs own website,
they say the signs of a prize scam is that number one,
you have to pay legitimate sweepstakes.
Don't make you pay a fee or buy something.
This is in contrast to what J Masini does. He forces you to buy his products?
Oftentimes he says, you know, Oh, you have to buy five items, seven items,
10 items from my site, but he's keeps saying you're going to win a ton of money.
And guys it's a lot. So here's just a few of them.
Thousand orders. I'll be placing in $12,000 in each order.
Thousand dollars. Okay. $12,000 pay attention, minimum.
Order, six misogyny, Italy products.
This is another one for the next 300 magaziney Italy orders.
I'll be placing it $40,000 in each order.
Okay. Think about that for 300 orders,
he's going to place $40,000 in each one.
And I know most of you guys already smell a gigantic scale, right? Obviously,
but he insists it's real guys. It's real. And let's do the math here. Okay.
I went and I checked.
What's the most Jamison he could be making off of this little little thing,
right? Let's say you buy the most expensive thing on his site. Well,
according to his own slider in the all item section,
most expensive product is $85. You're paying $85.
And minimum order is.
Minimum. Order is not magaziney Italy products.
So the max you can make per person is $765. And this guy is saying,
he's going to give away $40,000 to each of those people.
Meaning he's running at a net loss of $39,000
per customer. That's what he's saying. That's the math.
What comes next then should come as literally a surprise to know when people
start coming out of the word work saying that they were told by Jane Masini that
they won. And then they never got money.
I wasn't alive with Jim Azimi.
She told me I won $2,000, a house screen recorded and everything.
Now I am I supposed to believe one.
I was alive and I still didn't want it.
Of course, nothing's in the bags guys. I mean,
this should not come as a surprise to anyone.
You literally cannot do this giveaway. It's impossible. So what does this mean?
It means that if James and he's telling the truth and his clothing lines worth
$8 million,
he basically created that from nothing by telling people he's going to give away
all this money by lying to them. And how does he do it? Remember, again,
it all goes back to the beginning,
this image that he's cultivating isn't on accident.
He wants to be known as the guy who gives away money, right?
This is what he wants to be seen doing.
I just wanted to give you this for you.
This is all a facade though.
Literally he's doing this so that you believe in what he says.
I'll give you $40,000. I'll give you $12,000. I'll give you $10,000,
but it's not true. And ladies and gentlemen,
there's been an undercurrent of dissatisfied customers that have swept through
to the point where he's getting banned from various payment platforms.
Like he even got banned from PayPal. He no longer can use PayPal,
which is why he uses Zelle now. But in his Instagram story,
he's seen trying to buy a fresh PayPal because he got banned.
Look who has a PayPal.
They want to sell a business PayPal with a good reputation in history.
Basically he needs a business PayPal.
So he wants to buy one because he got banned from his current one because the
charge backs and the refunds that people are going through are insane.
But this is just further evidence of the scam it's falling apart.
This is to the point where he's even had to address and make up excuses for why
people aren't getting their money.
So one of the things he set out to do now is that the money which he's
supposedly sending in the mail,
he says he puts $40,000 or $10,000 into packages, physical packages.
He ships out to people. He says that the post office is stealing from them.
Postal workers are destroying boxes and taking the prizes.
And then they blame Jay for not getting the prize. So he's saying,
it's not my fault. You didn't get paid. Hey, ups stole money, stole your money.
And guys, that's not the only time he's addressed at sea. Jamie.
Zeni also went on bars on [inaudible] and addressed it there as well.
I went through a lot of accusations. I've done a lot for the community.
I know some people are selfish. They won't even do enough.
They won't even do nothing for anybody.
All right, guys, quit being selfish,
give away $40,000 to the next 300 people like Jay Manzini,
by the way, that's a giveaway of $12 million.
Keep in mind that this clown says his whole company is worth $8 million.
Although he doesn't have the cash in one giveaway, he promised $12 million.
But yeah,
he's a guy who does stuff for the community as opposed to selfish people.
I don't see bill Gates doing nothing for the community.
I'm not even going to get into this one.
Bill Gates has been taking a little heat online lately.
But to say that bill Gates doesn't do anything for the community while you do.
Yeah. Uh, this guy's clueless maybe because bill Gates, isn't going on.
Instagram live bragging. Every time he gives away money,
maybe that's why you don't see him as doing anything for the community.
I don't know.
Well, I'm telling you one thing, bro. There's a lot of people.
When I launched my brand, I did giveaways.
This gets into his biggest excuse and the biggest load of garbage you
will ever hear in your life. Okay?
This is how he reconciles not paying people money.
And then a lot of people lost at the end of the day. You're getting the product.
Right? Let's hear that again. A lot of.
People want a lot of people lost at the end of the day,
you're getting a product one more time.
What? I didn't pay you $40,000.
You bought the clothes cause you just wanted the clothes. No,
they bought your products because they wanted the money.
It's not at the end of the day. If you didn't win, you got a product.
No you're robbing people because the only reason they're going in and buying
your crappy clothes is because they want money.
It's not because they're in love with the [inaudible] brand.
He says this all the time. By the way, this is his big excuse.
He goes on entire rant about how he doesn't owe you anything.
Yeah. I'm in the house scam in the house. I got a clothing line.
I got an Academy. We sell clothes. We fix stocks.
You call it the brand of scam. Why? Because I can't give everybody money.
Instead of looking for something, go get up and work.
This is his big thing. Oh, I'm about people working. No,
you're running a giveaway scam.
Here's the incredible thing about this live by the way.
And you can't make this stuff up after going on this rant about how he needs
people to become self-sufficient what does he do? So, listen.
Starting now, since I'm fake,
starting now for the next hundred people to enroll in the Mathenia Academy,
be giving away $30,000 to each person. Let's rewind that again,
guys, for the next hundred people to enroll in the Messenia Academy,
let's pull out the calculator, be giving away $30,000 to each person.
How do you.
Right during a speech where he's saying you need to work the blah, blah, blah,
blah, and stop asking me for money.
He promises you $3 million in a giveaway.
So that's who Jay Masini is. In a nutshell, he's doing what is in my opinion,
the largest giveaway scam.
And we're going to tally up how much he's promised at the end of this video.
But I want to show you how often he does this because unfortunately,
even though repetition is repetitive, it also proves the point.
So let's walk through some of his giveaways. Okay?
And then at the end of this video,
I'm going to show you how much total he's promised versus how much he could have
made.
If every single person bought the most expensive item on his entire website.
Okay.
For the next thousand orders,
I'll be placing in $12,000 in each order, minimum order,
six misogyny, Italy.
Okay. So you just promised to wait $12 million and the total sales,
he would have reaped from that.
If everyone bought a minimum order of six and they paid the maximum amount per
item, $85, he would have made sales of $510,000,
but he promised 12 million. Okay.
This is another one for the next 300 magaziney Italy orders.
I'll be placing at $40,000 in each order.
Minimum order is not [inaudible] Italy products. It can't only be mass.
Okay? Same deal. He's trying to give away $12 million here as well,
just in different amounts, 300 orders, but he's giving away $40,000. This time,
minimum order of nine, meaning he can make $229,000. And again,
that's sales, not profit.
And this only applies for the next 800 people to send the $750.
Listen, when you win, you lose, you lose at the end of the day,
you're automatically getting an ebook. Yeah.
Again, the same thing where you're getting a product. Even if you lose no dude,
people aren't buying a minimum order of three magaziney eBooks in
order to get themselves smarter.
You got to purchase a minimum order of three machining Academy ebook.
Like why would someone buy three copies of a book?
That's your requirement of his sweepstakes? The there's so much fraud here.
It's insane. And the fact that it's still going on is still mind blowing to me.
This man has a million followers or close to a million followers on Instagram
and he's running a scam of this caliber. And where's the FTC on this.
The next 5,000 people to subscribe to that magaziney Academy,
I'll be selecting 200 winners giving them $10,000 each.
Okay. Another $2 million giveaway, casual, Oh boy,
this is one of my favorites here guys. Here.
We go for each person to place in one, a thousand dollar misogyny,
Italy order. It's a law book.
I'll be cutting out a check for $125,000.
You spend it.
Thousand dollars on his website. I'll pay you $125,000 for shopping.
Thanks for shopping, dude. What is bill Gates done for the community?
Well, the next 800 people to placing the order and the machining Italy site,
there'll be $40,000
in each order. Minimum.
Guys, that's $32 million.
He just promised a way on a live stream on Instagram either.
This man is Gandhi either.
He's a rich billionaire son who wants to burn through the money as fast as
humanly possible or he's defrauding customers.
You decide what you want to believe.
So I think that's enough evidence to sort of prove my point,
but I calculated out, you know,
how much money total he's promised and it's a hundred million dollars.
He's probably over a hundred million dollars.
And the maximum he could have made from those a hundred million dollars is
$7 million in sales. Coincidentally, uh,
pretty close to what he says his company is.
Is worth $8 million net worth. I'm not saying, like I said before,
I don't have 8 million cash, but it's my net worth. I do.
What he's doing right now is a leap. I'm going, I'm going to tell you right now,
you can't promise to give away money in exchange for payment, right?
You've changed for buying a product and then not give away the giveaway.
And it leads me to something else I kind of want to talk about,
which is this sort of a fake altruism that's been going around
recently. And I just want to go out on a limb here. I mean,
I know I'm going to sound like I'm entering conspiracy land,
crazy world. Y'all are going to say Steven, you've gone off the deep end,
but I want to humbly submit to you guys that these people may not be that
good. I'm not saying they're necessarily bad,
but you have to watch these people with the dose of skepticism.
Maybe they're not just doing it out of the kindness of their heart.
If every time they give away money, they have to film it.
There's nothing wrong with, you know,
saying that you're giving away money in order to raise awareness about an issue,
right? Like you're raising money for cancer. But at the same time,
if every time they do it, they have to get the camera crew. They have to say,
Oh, they have to say how much money they're giving. This is $8,000. You know,
I'm giving it to a poor person. Look how cool I am.
I don't know if that's your whole brand I'm suspicious. So yeah, that covers it.
I mean, I really wanted to go in depth with this one.
I think we have that we've definitively showed the scam as it
is. Uh,
you guys can't be doing these Instagram giveaways thinking you're going to get
away with it. People are going to catch on,
they are going to start cataloging it.
And eventually he will be caught ladies and gentlemen, thanks for coming by.
Thanks for watching spreadsheet in the link below.
If you want to go see the evidence for yourself and I'll see you in the next
one.
[Inaudible].